presso la Corte d'Assise del tribunale
di Vicenza è un corso in corso un
importante processo
ed è un processo in cui i capi di
puntazione sono molto gravi sono quello
di disastro ambientale e di
avvelenamento
di quello che è avvenuto di cui adesso
dirò
il
rappresentante delle Nazioni Unite in
Italia il relatore speciale dei diritti
umani e dei prodotti e dei rifiuti
tossici ha definito il più grande
inquinamento ambientale d'Europa Ma cosa
è successo È successo che un comune a
nord di Vicenza si chiama Trissino uno
stabilimento produttivo per alcuni anni
ha prodotto i cosiddetti pfas
Che cosa sono sono delle sostanze
chimiche sintetiche cioè sono delle
sostanze chimiche che non esistono in
natura sono le sostanze chimiche
chiamate per Poli
floroalchiliche e sono quelle che mi
fanno parte diciamo di quella grande
famiglia che in inglese si vengono
definite Forever chemicals cioè sono
quelle sostanze che una volta prodotta a
causa della grande
stabilità molecolare è molto difficile
smaltirla e quindi una volta prodotta
entra
negli esseri umani
nella natura e ha delle conseguenze che
sono delle conseguenze molto dure sono
conseguenze Anche nefaste perché quei
prodotti hanno delle caratteristiche
proprie o attenzione sono prodotti che
in commercio ci sono dal 1938 Avete
presente il Teflon quello che viene
utilizzato nelle padelle per evitare che
le bistecche si attacchino oppure alcuni
prodotti che vengono utilizzati per le
scarpe per renderle idrorepellenti
oppure per gli abiti oppure i vigili del
fuoco nelle schiume per spegnere gli
incendi oppure nell'elettronica
nell'elettronica avanzata Nell'era
spaziale per rendere più veloce La
trasmissione dei dati
Questo per dire che stiamo parlando di
prodotti non di nicchia Ma che hanno un
grandissimo spettro di applicazione
e quindi nel momento in cui noi
affrontiamo il tema Dobbiamo anche
essere consapevoli non solamente
dell'impatto ambientale ma anche da un
punto di vista dell'impatto sociale e
dell'impatto economico
questi prodotti sono prodotti che hanno
alcune caratteristiche sono appunto
resistenti e sono prodotti idrosolubili
si sciolgono nell'acqua e quindi sono
presenti nell'acqua sia di superficie
sia nell'acqua della falda delle falde
acquifere sono prodotti poi che sono
bioaccumulabili Cosa vuol dire vuol dire
che si accumulano nel corpo umano
direttamente indirettamente e dunque una
volta accumulati rimangono perché hanno
anche un'altra caratteristica lo
smaltimento il decadimento degli stessi
avviene nel corso di moltissimi anni
in Veneto
l'inquinamento da piffas ha colpito
direttamente attraverso l'acqua potabile
o indirettamente l'acqua di irrigazione
300 mila persone che sono monitorate dal
punto di vista sanitario le malattie di
questi prodotti sono innumerevoli molte
volte mortali
pensate che sotto quella terra c'è la
seconda più grande falda acquifera
d'Europa si estende a una dimensione
pari al Lago di Garda
Ebbene non è utilizzabile
E che cosa succede Stiamo costruendo una
condotta sotterranea che va a prendere
l'acqua dall'adige e la porta in quei
territori nei territori della provincia
di Vicenza nel territorio della
provincia di Verona nei territori della
provincia di Padova anche per le riga
dei campi perché vedete
i prodotti coltivati attraverso diciamo
l'irrigazione di quell'acqua poi non li
mangiano solo I veneti ma li mangiamo in
tutta Italia perché vengono portati in
giro quindi è una questione diciamo di
un impatto anche dal punto di vista
quantitativo assolutamente importante
E allora che cosa bisognava fare
bisognava fare delle leggi il primo
passaggio che abbiamo fatto con la
commissione parlamentare d'inchiesta è
quello di fare un Focus speciale cioè
un'inchiesta dedicata a quel caso un
anno di approfondimento di inchieste di
interrogatori di studi di visite in loco
E che cosa è emerso sono emerse molte
questioni sono emerse molti diciamo
mancanze Assente la prima della quale
manca e mancava nel nostro ordinamento
giuridico una legge che stabilisce i
dati stabilisce i limiti di legge
appunto oltre i quali non si può
produrre e non si può soprattutto
rilasciare in ambiente nelle varie
matrici ambientali Come si dice
tecnicamente l'acqua l'aria il terreno
via dicendo Ecco allora che abbiamo
depositato un disegno di legge al Senato
un disegno di legge di cui sono stato
relatore e un disegno di legge che
appunto stava cercando di coprire Questo
Gap pensate
che la questione dei pifars è talmente
importante che l'attuale presidente
degli Stati Uniti l'ha inserito
all'interno del discorso che ha
depositato nel momento di insediamento
alla Casa Bianca e ha messo a capo del
dipartimento Anzi dell'agenzia
dell'ambiente degli Stati Uniti colui
che aveva fatto la battaglia contro i
pifas
che se avete curiosità potete vedere un
film appena uscito Uscito nel 2019 che
si intitola cattive acque che parte
appunto da un'inchiesta giornalistica
che poi ha dato avvio a tutto quello che
è successo per esempio quella
Amministrazione
l'amministrazione biden ha fatto delle
leggi molto stringenti molto vinconanti
a livello federale per esempio l'Unione
Europea sta facendo altrettanto
attraverso una direttiva europea che è
già stata emanata e dunque gli stati
membri devono adeguare il proprio
sistema legislativo a quella
Allora dicevo questo disegno di legge
Purtroppo non è andato a buon fine
mancava poco così ma la caduta del
governo ha bloccato l'iter e quindi
adesso va ripreso in mano
Però noi ci siamo accorti di un'altra
cosa
non era sufficiente affrontare il tema
dei pifas era necessario affrontare la
questione dell'ambiente a 360 gradi ed
era necessario non solo affrontarlo dal
punto di vista delle leggi ordinarie Ma
dovevamo superare un gap
Cioè Dovevamo inserire il tema
all'interno del patto costituzionale
della nostra Repubblica E quindi
dovevamo inserire il tema all'interno
della Costituzione Io ho avuto l'onore
di far parte della commissione ristretta
che ha scritto quel testo Non solo che
ha scritto il testo poi siamo riusciti a
far sì che l'intero Parlamento in
quattro passaggi legislativi come
previsto dalla costituzione in pochi
mesi l'ha trasformato in legge
costituzionale Quindi se voi adesso
prendete la Costituzione troverete
l'articolo 9 dell'articolo 41 modificato
l'articolo 9 la modifica dell'articolo 9
è stata una cosa storica perché mai
nella storia della Repubblica si era
modificato uno degli articoli
quelli dei primi 12 articoli che sono
gli articoli che definiscono
costituiscono i principi fondamentali
della Costituzione non abbiamo toccato
nulla di ciò che esisteva abbiamo
aggiunto ciò che mancava non certo
perché i nostri padri costituenti non
fossero personale all'altezza tutt'altro
ma semplicemente perché nel 1946 47 48
non c'era quella sensibilità e quindi
bisognava intervenire cosa abbiamo
inserito abbiamo inserito nell'articolo
9 che la Repubblica tutela l'ambiente la
biodiversità gli ecosistemi
nell'interesse delle future generazioni
Guardate quest'ultima parte anche
è fondamentale perché abbiamo inserito
all'interno della Costituzione Il
principio della solidarietà
intergenerazionale oltre che al
intragenerazionale che c'era già in
maniera consistente
ciò sta a dire che da quel momento in
poi ogni legge ogni norma ogni accordo
di programma
ogni attività
di enti pubblici o privati deve
rispettare quanto stabilito dalla
costituzione e cioè non deve guardare
solamente all'attuale generazione ma
deve guardare le generazioni future
quelle dei miei figli quelle dei vostri
figli quella di mia nipote e quelle dei
vostri nipoti è un passaggio importante
abbiamo poi inserito sempre in
quell'articolo A tutela degli animali è
stato molto complicato perché dovevamo
trovare un equilibrio tra Chi sostiene
che gli animali siano esseri senzienti
vedi tra stato di Lisbona e chi invece è
il contrario stabiliva in base al codice
civile italiano che gli animali sono
cose di cui la persona può disporre
capite bene che trovare l'equilibrio non
è stato molto semplice abbiamo poi
modificato l'articolo 41 che è
l'articolo delle libertà economiche in
cui abbiamo naturalmente riconosciuto
lasciato il fatto che le iniziative
economiche libera è appunto uno dei
capisaldi la nostra Costituzione ma non
può svolgersi in danno abbiamo aggiunto
alla salute e all'ambiente capite bene
come si lega all'esempio che facevo
All'inizio dei
questa mattina
20 novembre del 2022 all'alba si è
conclusa la Coop 27 in Egitto Io ho
avuto modo di rappresentare il
Parlamento italiano Lo scorso anno nella
coppa 26 e ho rappresentato il
Parlamento in italiano anche nella
grande conferenza di parlamenti mondiali
sul tema del cambiamento climatico
è il tema che lega tutti i paesi del
mondo Tutti è il tema che lega tutti i
paesi del mondo non ce n'è uno che si
senta al di fuori ci sono poi approcci
diversi Ma certamente è il tema che lega
tutti i paesi del mondo la conferenza
dei Nairobi per fare un esempio sulle
migrazione ha stabilito che già oggi è
sempre di più domani
la prima motivazione causa
dell'immigrazione del fenomeno
dell'immigrazione e delle migrazioni
Dunque è legata al cambiamento climatico
in particolare La siccità
ma potremmo fare anche gli esempi in
Italia la tempesta vaia che ha colpito
le Dolomiti tre anni fa è una tempesta
di una dimensione che non sarà mai vista
al 20 a 217 km all'ora oppure il
fenomeno delle Acque alte a Venezia
nella mia città non c'è mai stata con
quella intensità se Voi leggete la porta
della ipcc l'ultimo del 2022 vedete che
dice in maniera univoca
univoca che se non interveniamo
strutturalmente
entro il 2100 il Mediterraneo sarà più
alto del 70 gli 80 centimetri Il che
vuol dire che la mia città la città di
Venezia verrà sommersa e gran parte
delle Coste Italiane subiranno la stessa
fine
Questo è il fenomeno che Stiamo
affrontando ci sono però dei segnali
positivi che dobbiamo guardare che
dobbiamo accompagnare Beh innanzitutto
c'è una consapevolezza che sta crescendo
grazie a Dio nessuno quasi nessuno ormai
mette in dubbio il fatto che ci sia un
incidenza diretta dell'attività umana
col cambiamento climatico non era così
fino a qualche anno fa Quindi l'attività
antropica è un elemento decisivo nel
cambiamento climatico Questa
consapevolezza sta crescendo
sta crescendo poi soprattutto è nata
diciamo nella nell'America Latina una
nuova consapevolezza che sta facendo
fare un salto di qualità in questa
direzione Cioè non più solamente un
diritto
ambientale
ma il diritto dell'ambiente Cioè non
solo l'ambiente oggetto del diritto Ma
l'ambiente è titolare del diritto Questo
è un cambiamento giuridico fondamentale
di filosofia del diritto che sta dando e
darà dei risultati straordinari in
futuro
abbiamo poi la grande leva della
tecnologia la tecnologia se usata con
intelligenza è una cosa molto positiva
per esempio l'energia nucleare da
fusione che non è ancora Diciamo in
essere soprattutto non è in essere dal
punto di vista industriale lo sarà tra
qualche decennio è certamente una
grandissima opportunità
ma pensiamo per esempio ad alcune
sperimentazioni molto interessanti per
esempio in Islanda la capacità
direttamente di captare e di prendere la
CO2 dell'atmosfera e trasformarla in
materiali inerte che poi Può essere
utilizzata all'interno di svariati
processi produttivi oppure pensiamo alle
energie rinnovabili
che sono la grandissima opportunità per
il nostro paese Innanzitutto perché sono
le energie che sono sostenibili dal
punto di vista ambientale ma lo sono
anche dal punto di vista sociale
economico perché solo l'energia più
basso costo di produzione
sono l'energia del domani e sono
l'energia che consentono un equilibrio e
consentono l'autonomia energetica Cioè
non dover dipendere di volta in volta da
questo o da quell'altro paese
e poi da ultimo c'è un dato che io
ritengo essere assolutamente
significativo e straordinario
l'impatto dei movimenti giovanili sulle
questioni ambientali
l'impatto è un impatto grande
c'è una consapevolezza nel mondo
giovanile che nella mia generazione non
c'era c'è una consapevolezza della
necessità di intervenire che nella mia
generazione non c'era
c'è una consapevolezza che noi dobbiamo
alimentare che dobbiamo accompagnare c'è
questa consapevolezza che diventa un
impegno Certamente per me Per la mia
generazione Ma certamente è anche uno
straordinaria possibilità di sviluppo di
crescita sostenibile per me per voi e
per i nostri figli Grazie
[Applauso]